welcome everyone great to see such a big
crowd that the semester gets late and
people get busy and fur this is the
second to last imagine our almost
remarks off series am I named stretches
beyond the associate director of the
oral history master's program here at
Columbia and this series is part of the
course work for our master students and
also obviously is open to the public and
so I'm getting passed around this signup
sheet and if anyone is here that's not
on the server want to hear more about
our work counties do science and I also
mentioned that this event is
co-sponsored by the communications ph.d
program at the journalism school and as
part of the Paul F lagerfeld lecture
series which explores and exciting new
ways of combining methodologies McMahons
and Social Sciences so of all the events
that were protecting the semester
editing candidates and sort of embodies
that in the most powerful am so excited
to hear much anticipation i am andrew
has a recent graduate of our master's
program the Norns generic from yet i'm
aware that she worked in public radio
broadcasting in production for Georgia
Public Radio and American boys break and
and she did a master's thesis here on
how individual social networks change
over time and for that she did something
really innovative methodological and
that she combined a network analysis and
cognitive mapping right and to show how
these social networks looked and then to
show new things about how they change
over time at a gifted girls program
called Mary Baldwin so she's currently a
doctoral candidate
in the HD programming communications
here at the journalism school and for
that she's exploring the epistemology of
interviews caring and contrasting
journalism or on the street and she's
interested broadly and the philosophy of
social science so being turn it over to
you and thank you so much Amy commercial
part 4 for this opportunity to talk to
you about my research and implementation
work Nathan 20 year of spirit of legend
so let me get right into it as my top
will consider two approaches to oral
history interviewing that acknowledge
the social world these approaches on
sociology college for social system
ology so those of you who are less
familiar with oral history let's begin
with the most basic question what is for
all the street
so what's a big thank you to trim the
oral history of you and any other time
Oh every interview was a conversation
between two or more people just like
we're having right now but in oral
history interview we are we have a
different objective in mind we're trying
to get the person to really speak
expansively about their experiences and
their memories journalists frequently
have very specific questions and they
really would prefer short answers to the
point in oral history interview we're
going to ask open-ended questions and we
hope that the person will talk a lot in
fact you would prefer to ninety percent
of the interview p speaking by me be
spoken by the the interview subject
which would be quite different from the
journal symptom are there any other
differences between these types of
interviews yes there really are several
differences the the product of an oral
history interview is going to be a
lightly edited transcript of the
interview that will go into the archives
where researchers can come in and read a
journalist does his interview usually
takes it or maybe just takes notes and
draws out the few quotations that he
needs restore it or she needs and that's
usually hit there are only one other
story the next day and the interview is
forgotten in the case of the oral
history interview we are hoping that it
will be used by many people in the
future so we are going to prepare a
transcript regarding that the
interviewee review that transcript
correct errors and if there are any
parts of it that they're not comfortable
with will let them restricted for a time
we rather have the interview
for the future than sacrifice not
getting it just simply because the
person isn't comfortable with some of
the things they might have said we'll
also have a person sign legal document
in which they give us permission to let
other people we interview and quote from
it and in some cases they sign their
copyright interest in the interview over
to the University which is a legal
transfer of their property interview and
that's very different than most other
interviews so did you conduct some of
these interviews from the project
yourself yes I did and I was a to
interview so that was a pretty straight
forward primer history of the keys from
Penn State harvest and historian pull
the story at least out and the term
world history refers as he said both
reaction and the results of that
interaction transcripts recordings and
analysis so as you saw we stout made the
long history interview clearer by
contrast with journalism and that poor
mystery is really a human research
methodology it calls upon practitioner
to actually create their sources it's
both the process of a product but for
the purposes of this talk and my
research project a little refer only to
the process that is the oil district
interview interactions when it's a long
history interviewed our office day I
mean interview the purposes of this talk
so all the story of sita interview as a
way to access information about the past
as connected with the president to pull
their own wrong really these interviews
are conversational narratives a kind of
communication of them the world will
gather information and supplement
recusing historical records while
simultaneously constituted constituting
a self-standing meaning making a record
of human subjectivity so my introduction
to a theoretical account the interview
interaction took place primarily during
my time in the oma program before the
screen masters program we're with my
fellow students i engaged with the work
of leading oral historians like really
alessandro for telling lisa pass
remaining lynne abrahams and others so
some aprons and all the story of her who
i will borrow liberally throughout this
talk oral history is a dialogic process
a conversation in real time between the
interviewer is a narrator within an area
we might call external discourses for
culture therefore old history is
apparently a social process so i found
the sociological account of the oral
history interview as a communication
event most helpful indeed it was the
examination of symbolic interactionist
literature like like like the work of
transfer cruelly tortured me for boomer
or urban goffman incredibly helpful as i
try to understand what was happening
possibility views so symbolic
interactionism just understand the field
refers to the simultaneous engagement of
a conversation of gestures and use
significant symbols and everyday
communication to quote me be able to
make your feirense as I mentioned there
truly mean rumor government so just to
begin as I started thinking about the
interview that's what would some mild
contractions say happens during the
so they might say that barriers
constructive express social realities of
series of interactions based on meaning
simples and the underlying assumptions
thereof so trying to convert order the
remainder of my talk arising out of this
understanding and the continual practice
of oral history interviewing all
historians have constituted useful
bodies of knowledge pertaining to the
evolution of oral history into practice
and they offered an account of knowledge
as arising from the interview for export
to other engaged fields of study so now
with this court understanding in tow
allow me to to tell you about how the
destructions talking to two parts first
first I'm going to discuss a topic of
interest
that is a theory of the relational
social world to individual subjectivity
'he's that is a sociology knowledge and
this will lead into a discussion of my
empirical dissertation process excuse me
of my empirical dissertation project as
it currently stands second I will
earnestly and tentatively approach to
social epistemology of oral history
interviewing by explaining four major
oral history concepts and counting from
the basis and four fundamental aspects
of the interview interaction I approach
these frames for reflection on oil
history interviewing in order to
understand the theoretical bedrock of
the dissertation project and future
projects that I hope to pursue
so let's begin with a sociology
knowledge so the sociology of knowledge
is an empirical study access assessing
the social conditions for causes of
knowledge in a given society field was
initiated by rob van Hien was under the
influence of work by Karl Marx and
Friedrich Engels at the end of the 19th
century we started putting century the
clearest treatment for our purposes of
this topic is the social construction of
reality by Peter Berger and Thomas
luqman for sociologists of knowledge the
issue of the conditions knowledge that
issue does not pertain to a
philosophical project instead it
corresponds to the adoption of
sociological approaches and
methodologies to undercut uncover the
theories of knowledge active and the
empirical social world the field
contends that knowledge is socially
constructed and understanding their
lives on to compete
so
first sociologists acknowledge consider
the existence of an objective world as a
given this approach was adopted to avoid
the philosophical project for which the
tools of sociology often proved
inadequate moreover the field
acknowledges that the man in the street
regard social structures as social facts
that is as objective reality the
Philosopher's may rightly question their
substantive people interact within
social worlds as though their
constituent parts intertwine these
soobak intertwined symbolic universes
were immutable were fundamental were in
a faithful these beliefs become a
recently solidified over time the
processes of objectification and
reification causing actors to view the
social world as a given interaction with
these social structures produces a
subjective reality however the full
range of subjectivity constituting the
social world are produced from earliest
childhood in which the child who
possesses the capacity for sociality is
programmed by the subject to these
letters to view herself in a certain
light and the early development of
children along with comprehension of
time and space and place self arises as
an organized collection of information
adopted from interaction with other
individual cells identity then takes
shape as that imparted relation
individual itself to the generalized of
it that is on the presence of a
seemingly immutable social relations
instructors thus the interaction is
individual with the social reality to
which he defers constitutes a form of
social collective consciousness these
intellectual movements we can track so
now I will offer a brief account of the
development of all history theory and
practice on time through the lens of
sociology of knowledge today practice
born of the struggle for legitimacy
reaching toward maturity the school
historians push her space and
acknowledgement Vita the processes that
Burberry luv Nanda terms of
justification to education segmentation
legitimation reification these processes
ultimately aimed toward the constitution
of a symbolic universe with which
individuals can interact or all the
saurians had and continue to push when
confronted particularly when confronted
by intellectual influence
opponents among the strength and tactics
of oral history in this battle is the
extension of oral history methodology
into many enterprises whether
disciplined practice for community
oriented this leads to a variety of
practitioners engaging with oral history
methods which resulted a kind of success
across the humanities and Social
Sciences as well as outside academia
allowing diversion expertise to
contribute to our field as alessandro
vitelli so athlete says all history is
permeable and borderless a composite
genre which requires that we think
flexibly across any between disciplinary
boundaries in order to make the most of
this rich and complex source all history
is very different before surgery in a
way it was conceived in 20 focusing on
oil industry is practice in the United
States we begin with former slaves who
completed first-person autobiographical
narrative in 1718 and nineteenth
centuries however it is not into active
a collection and recognition of American
slave narratives collected in the 1930s
as part of the federal works project
that oral history became a sort of pub
by practice such archives fail to
attract attention from academic
historians up until many decades later
as they were considered quote Abraham's
untrustworthy and there
50 initially conceived and implemented
at columbia university by alan evans the
purpose of archiving oral history for
academic piece was clear that is to
collect the narratives of great men and
retainment for posterity in europe
particularly in britain and accessories
written records have also been favored
over old sources however no rediscovery
a significant proform traditions largely
outside around the fringes of academia
allow oral history to develop across the
come in the 1950s in the 1950s and 60s
sum of all the stories gained national
recognition for instance Studs Terkel
whose radio programs and books
introduced oral history to the masses
throughout the last half of the 20th
century the 1970's and 80's saw it
expanded base
was familiar with oral history and
greatly expanded discourse including
feminist leftist liberal approaches and
the fields increasing challenges social
scientific notions of validity the field
work towards a legitimacy all its own
largely light of a work of theorists and
practitioners like her Ultron really
innocent as Nene incorporation of
additional practitioners into the field
and growing self acceptance of the
uniqueness in college it's both
technology too low these days oral
history this established practice of
research into I stand top and
disciplines is vibrant units technology
anthropology sociology healthcare study
in psychology as an evidential pool and
legal medical caring environment with
the materials archives is valuable
references and library and archival
spaces around the world so obviously I
have had at this later stage and not
engage with oral history as such that is
as an establish structure with bridging
ideals and what's attractive thus I
prism subject of my dissertation having
to find and dispense the world history
interview
nice that beliefs concerning forestry
may be shared and implemented to varying
degrees of the frog field I suspect that
in discussions with oral history
interviewers one would hear substantial
evidence of these knowledge and sign of
appropriate and human practices as
distributed throughout the field and
additional of my time in rows of silence
as practitioners approached oral history
differently there are coaches resonated
with simple exploring the bounds of
practice sometimes escaping them so I'm
taking that project up for my
dissertation work I would pursue an oral
history project consisting of interviews
with oral historians about their
interview practices to the origins of
those practices while recording
behaviors certainly differs
substantially from actual behaviors I
suspect that my study wheels interesting
information concerning those practices
with substantive I and across the field
that's why oppose the purses those that
have more mass adoption excuse me that's
why I use this projects provisional
title interviewing interviewers about
interviewing it is about reflecting the
practitioner in time about the practice
by the practice it's pretty net so for
purposes of background research I'm
obsessed dominant and hewa guides and
counsel history for dominant themes and
specific recommendations listen for
their echoes or lack thereof and
interview responses for textual and
discourse analysis tools how I like the
themes reference the silences more
silences providing some indication the
requirements and preferences of the
field as a whole eventually for
comparative purposes I may perform the
same operation for long-form broadcast
email print interviewers offering a
comparative analysis as you heard
earlier from my oral history work by
examining another fields interviewing
approach I will examine that Gil's
recommendations concerning the NFU along
with interviewers reporting practices
discussing how or if these standards are
presented
lord obviously the direct comparison of
reporting a recorded interview standards
of styles could prove to be a profitable
opportunity drawing the distinctness of
each practice and to start belief
perhaps my interviews will look
something
our news to use that gathering
information gathering news there are the
confrontational interview i did use with
and six stars anything interviewers into
news with interviews about interview my
name is mike wallace said I'm reported
and studs terkel I'm not waters cars
because I never quite know what to say
that I knew I guess television
journalist would be a part of it I call
myself a disc jockey who talks a lot if
you're going to do a job you might
people to pay attention to what you do
in that job and how to separate yourself
from the rest there is a point man
interview if it's personality we're
sorry if it isn't I guess where
something goes thing I know that you've
got something special I guess what it
comes down to is this if you feel that
I'm I'm hearing into a camera at this
moment and there's a very light here's a
light over there tonight I've never
talked to an interviewer handle his own
camera as you just don't care if you
want in or watching all right the most
satisfying interview is the one in which
you mean that you have gotten the enemy
leader to get all of them accounts and
people simply begin to talk what are the
other and that's going to be at that
moment of accelerators happens a lot
Thanks get blouberg for that out of that
clip so they might my interviews will
look at some of that I look like some of
that may be without the guy could time
work and the guy coming up end but
nevertheless i'm sure i will approach
some of those faces so ok so moving on
I've got further questions and those
questions demand a new approach so now
you know about my dissertation topic is
I really want to understand some of the
bedrock understandings of our
all-district practice indeed individual
and individual oral historian throughout
the 20th century have to go practice
work towards self-determination against
and grew seemingly immutable academic
structures even as those same structures
produce the oral historian themselves in
many cases and by extension all
interfering practice occurring Abrams
and history of oral
which research practice community that
is doing that interpreting are deeply
entwined and in fact emerged
simultaneously however along the way all
historians have sometimes unreflective
Lee developed allegiances with theorists
as they develop a largely internal
account for their practice intentionally
for some and unwittingly for others all
historians have committed themselves to
common beliefs concerning the interview
I would like to take the last 15 minutes
of this talk to examine some of these
beliefs and identify eerie stairs and
other fields mainly in philosophy and
sociology who's worth offers a thorough
account of complex accounts of some of
these bedrock understandings concerning
the pervasiveness of the social roles
within the interviews interaction
okay so first and foremost let me say i
am not a philosopher not and i'm not
even going to attempt to to to be a
philosopher but what I will say is I
think it's certainly fair someone
engaged in oral history practice and
fine to locate theorists whose works may
speak somehow to ours even and
especially if or when we struggle to
understand as I often do so with that in
mind accessing you a simple question
what is oral histories accounts of the
relevance of social relations roles
interests and institutions we're all
it's making you understanding as we do
that world history theory has emerged
and continues to emerge alongside
practice thus we are approaching kind of
democratic also focus molecules you will
well classical at this technology has
many things but democratic isn't
necessarily one of them so while we
appeal to the most democratic so I'm
going to appeal the most democratic
approach I can find
local cities and the late 20th century
philosophical dialectic called social
technology which uses possible kiss
technology as a base so I'm going to use
tells work except supplement to a
broader conversation so what follows I
apply world history to that dialectic
attempting to locate epistemic homes for
bedrock concepts and all the strength in
it so the core question is what is the
oral historians theoretical basis for an
understanding of what's happening in the
role is to educate provide ascension
whatever
functions of our own practice
okay so start what is the best analogy
so when we discussed this analogy we
discuss the falafel approach to
knowledge its limitations or apartments
in nature from foundations the city of
epistemology has been concerned with
many fundamental questions he's included
for me technology understanding the
source or basis of knowledge and the
media the terms i just mentioned study
was motivated by a french philosopher
game of cards concerned that much of a
pair of knowledge might not prove to be
true this worry prompted the
foundational scoffs persia writers and
meditations on first philosophy were in
which is possibility that all apparent
knowledge could prove false settling on
the pieces cogito ergo sum I think
therefore I am from this piece of stick
cart was able to constitute a theory of
how other compositions could be
validated based on kaja to all the
personalities of 1641 on as a response
to date cards right whether our purposes
whether Baconian Lockean or communion
enlightenment
see if acknowledged that is justified
belief as resulting from the proper
methods engagement of perception and
rural status United States regard to
justification social relations to only
support another method extend perception
in order to support a method or
obfuscated two methods for knowledge
best social relations were or were just
not terribly useful to the studied thus
testimony acted under sideshow to the
primary work or worse it distracted from
the primary work and so testimonial
beliefs of which were primarily
concerned is the wrong historians
retained that secondary status so what
this very basic understanding of the
emergence of histology of the dye
Olympic
sorry so what a social epistemology go
back but having explains how inherently
social that interview interaction is you
would be remiss to apply the standards
to our work social epistemologists on
the other hands and knowledge to choose
that seems readily apparent to the oil
historian that knowledge has arrived
that distributed perpetuated in through
and by social role this prompted 18th
century Scottish philosopher Thomas free
to conclude testimonial belief as a
component of the broader category to
believe deriving a perception for which
robust justifications already existed
and doing so free throws with a
traditional assignments and secondary
status to believe indebted to social
relations that is testimony so in doing
so he founded social pathology as a
philosophical subject so quite a social
epistemology matter and matter for us
this is the term that is most relevant
to our our practice oral history for
this epistemological framework speaks
directly to the elements of our practice
which move milton preoccupied however it
does columnist to educate the basis of
our practice with them credibly
so our question with this basically
we're standing on the emergence of
social
as a dialectic let's examine what it
might say to dominantly stop all history
and we should be acknowledged that
making theorists to make theorists who
social epistemology is a classic
epistemology speak to is the
underpinnings of our practice and follow
the schema is one of my own creation and
it's derived partially from the issues
of rest by Abrams in her book oral
history theory so this is how I'm going
to approach it so just for a foundation
for what follows the questioning and
questioning the epistemology of the
world history and what I really
considered most fundamental aspects of
that interview scenario here I consider
coherence as fundamental narrative
subjectivity is fundamental to
tivity language is fundamental to
performance himself as committed to
memory suffice to say that in the
remainder of thought I was in the
historical account of these dielectrics
and no favors what I aim to do instead
is to explain the dominant or historical
approach to a concept followed by a
pinpointing of total custom ologist
their theories that may provide some
epic backing to a generalized all
historical account okay narrative
coherence so in discussing that relation
what's don't narrative the word
narrative is ubiquitous and all mystery
circles it's a fundamental component of
our practice narrative is one of the
ways people make sense of and structure
their experiences communicate themselves
and others is a process of imposing
order on the disorganized content of
experience the structure may incorporate
any number of dispersant elements
including
ization and saturation etc we do it
automatically in our everyday
interaction with others world history
has adopted the approach allows
importunities to construct their own
meanings and their own narratives the
ideal is to allow the lead to construct
their own form of narrative coherence
and side so brief treatment of coherence
and oral history brought history makes
no claims to objective truth to an
objective truth but only it doesn't make
claims the subjective coherence and the
opportunity for analysis that results
for all historians the goal of the
interview has the achievement a mirror
of coherence and indeed narrative is a
kind of cook yards and it's appealed to
oral historians obvious it is a natural
component of the object of our study
just testimony on the basis of coherence
all the saurians have become bolder
proponents of the strength of our
practice without resorting to a sense to
prove the objective the litany of
interviewing the accounts interesting
considerations from epistemology
possible histology include week
individualism endorsed by the human
which acknowledged that there exists
some beliefs which cannot and therefore
need not be verified firsthand this is
the dominant view of testimony and it
requires that testimonial nice be
justified however on the basis of not
testimonial police however there exists
multiple accounts of the sweep
individualism and coherent ISM offers
personality to oral histories
appearance as a way to validate an
individual or collection areas based on
the degree to which the collection of
assertions beliefs an account makes
sense in the context of a hold that's a
coherent test with accounts that Thun
relevant role is to practice win games
eh Bradley wine Bonjour wolf rasselas
snow tainted with or not cost plus okay
okay so next I will address the relation
of interest subjectivity subjectivity
all historians recognize the process of
our work is necessarily multifocal
containing many voices and many social
situated perspectives or subjectivities
there is the interviewers there is the
interviewees and new number of voices
roles perspectives and agencies that are
brought along this interplay is what
world story is ecology subjectivity as a
result of may arise conflict between
multiple concision worlds to quote
Abrams the descriptive character of
these relations may vary substantially
for interactions interaction that
nevertheless factors into subjects
well the bedrock subjectivity is IU
subjectivity when we speak of
subjectivity were referring to a
personal subject normally a person in
this context of objectivity which is the
position of existence independence of
perspective portion for all historians
that Pacific debate over the
subjectivity or objectivity of narrators
is not only questioned every element of
the oral history interview a subjective
indeed oral history is subjectivity so
for us there's no escaping it to vote
for telling all sources tell us not just
what people did but what they wanted to
do but they believed they were doing and
what they think they did but all the
earliest accounts of subjection even be
found in the work of the German idealism
engl comp and healing Hagel later
extended by hallmark since employee
whose post-money work provided for the
deconstruction and analysis of the
subject post modern thinkers Louis out
loser and shove the cloak and Pierre
will go together integrated the subject
into the social world conceiving of it
construction her testimony and language
so for this relation again
the testimony so for all the story of
sense ammonia is material which we work
and the subject of our analysis
testimony consists of two elements
speech and performance both are symbolic
interactionist languages conveyed in
order to enhance the audience's
understanding and engagement and
storytelling the two elders intertwined
with one another over the course of
narrative meaning is conveyed both by
the words themselves as well as by hand
gestures body postures baritones voice
all starting to make note of these
aspects of the interview as they shift
and we take throughout the attraction
col Abrams a formal question and answer
session might mutate into a more formal
dialogue or conversation mode the soil
experience adopted open and his approach
contending the unexpected and every
interaction thus this interest objective
testimonial narrative that's the step of
world history and a thorough treatment
of language in this context is
impossible at a time allotted and
probably impossible show however in
consideration of the very types of
language and then bending in tribute the
engagement of socially constructed to
both worlds and vast web of foundational
beliefs that must be held in common to
facilitate speech suffice to say that
semantic theorists have much to say more
historians
the particular out recommend and
exploration of mediating referenced
areas offer title training Bertrand
Russell the nineteenth and twentieth
centuries they separated sense of the
word and reference of the word the
silent that continues twentieth the 21st
century city of work ethic and shine so
Peter strae and John so exposition of
modern and postmodern approaches to
reform include delay terrific and shine
for post modern approaches to
performance include the dramaturgical
literature Erving Goffman and
epistemology is a later pick each time
specialist for tinnitus or both
structures across four continents all 50
who were shadows to foreshadow the
preoccupation art with subjective
realities of social life and last but
not least I'm going to address the
relation of memory to self oral
historians understand and who use as an
entry point situated in the present to
access past indeed our interview needs
our products of memory our historical
documents that is to say our
interviewees particularly capable and
accuracy bias but all historians view
this as an opportunity to examine why
the narratives are that way why its
emphasis given to certain moments to
such memories enough to others present
different silences would feel a great
deal about the social order to interview
me and habits and appreciate your ex
Middle East Studies is a bathtub filled
ball as we said he's generally focusing
on collective memory into which I will
not go but suffice to say that all the
stories do not beat a memory in a
passive sentence on the contrary with
each telling a narrative memory
reconstitute itself of ameri memory
feels personal it is always influenced
by shared memories and silences as in
movies actually is work with italian
fascism however memory is also there are
scientific sense a mechanical retrieval
encoding and story a memory in various
parts of the brain with each of these
understandings of memory we can start
potential would need the guarantee and
bring stability both in the interpretive
and chemical sense so the memory we have
done to see himself and it'll be leads
produced memory they address the
persistence of themselves over time and
space and doing so I reflect on the
history of a mean it's allegiances
conceptions and purposes but never its
perceptions as me neither thanks
northfield's this negotiation between a
conscious actor and that actors
existence in social world is a mutable
process never fully captured symbolic
interactionism george herbert meet would
say that self is present when the mine
interacts i don't move itself by an
internal
her with another self casting an image
capable of being analyzed and interested
epistemological assessments of South
holiday price dualist consept of the
body's relation with the soul has
mechanic material misty interacting with
the non-material 9 jun hwa conceived for
consciousness as the basis of personal
identity later they can even see of
himself as a Commonwealth which the
whole is instantly constituted by parts
the loss of a part is not necessarily
mean the loss of the whole the notion of
an individualized self thought that is
union distinguish from others those
related to distinguish from others it's
interesting the Cartesian
epistemological project the foundation
of classical and social
as all historians as all the screens the
sheriff commitment to self narrating
performative testimony though we utilize
various methods to achieve those innings
since narrative intersubjectivity
performance and memory are fundamental
to our practices oral historians
likewise coherence subjectivity language
itself should be fundamental
considerations as well these dialectics
form of bedrock often hidden from the
firts practitioner nevertheless our
understanding with them deeply affects
for all industry very and in practice
our treatment of these topics finds
interlocutors and philosophical and
sociological discipline so it is prudent
to examine them for our aziz this
especially this is especially the case
given all industries definite though
occasionally overblown it's legible and
a political potential across a multitude
fields and within our own we should
examine these conclusions to see if they
serve our purpose as well as it's
constructive for fields to identify
parents various interests and to create
conversation around them I do so with
the whole 10 as we advance our oral
history practice we will also advance
full count as our field has done for
nearly a century so I don't think he's
taught roots what I'm aware that I've
lost over a great will important topics
but I hope that in the skipping
understanding of expression of our
fields knowledge of the all-australian
came from advantage of sociology and
knowledge and social technology of the
field struggle for legitimacy of
historical context despite the
complexities of the using living source
material and it's understanding of the
social world and energy practice and did
not at the least I hope that I increased
somewhat your interest
questions of all
and raise your awareness of some
thinkers outside our field to engage
them
thank you